hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I woke up to you again oh
my god you are very loud we're back to
normal okay so this is not a horror game
as far as they know this is a game about
waking up next to someone after a not-so
one-night stand as far as I know I woke
up yeah we did and then what happened
hello dr. dot dot I woke up next to her
or him
let's say her for the sake of argument I
moved to a new place recently and found
someone woke up next to me she told me
hey this is a one-time thing have this
in fact and I said yeah of course me too
and here we are
hi that was pretty good you should get
going
excused you why are you hello Hey
look it's been great but it'd be best
for the both of us kept this a two-night
stand i completely agree
30 minutes Stan you need sure yeah all
right well that's what we agreed to Jeff
no time for that it's complicated stuff
hey great idea I'll add you on facebook
and put our status as it's complicated
okay
just kid Jeff JK not really cuz that
would be making it more than a do
nightstand I'm gonna be late where are
my pants ah on the floor throw my
dresser they magically disappeared
thrown out the window well I don't know
which one of these is true
can any of them be true they've
magically disappeared
they're all my dresser baby
pants are on my dresser Thanks a sad
I'd say SIA but wealth goodbye
I kept meeting her after that
not on purpose we just seem to be in the
right place at the right time she'd say
something like what a coincidence nice
to see you again and I'd reply I've
gotta go I'll reply I gotta go I gotta
get air want to grab a drink want to
come over to my place want to go over to
my place grab a drink
come over yeah want to come over to my
place she was charming I never could
refuse I feel so tired afterwards
doesn't feel good at all we still do it
morning I've been thinking I'm ready to
make a commitment to our relationship of
repeated one-night stands ha ha
what about you me too sure all right
me too I'm ready for this relationship
to level up awesome so there's a gap in
my phone contacts it's just waiting to
be filled I'll fill it here's no no I
don't care if that sounds like a
euphemism I'm not about that here's my
number
yeah there you go call me I'm hoping
between 10 and 9
what no midnight shifts face like it's a
quarter's work phase like this requires
a lot of work you don't even understand
that much work got to get my beauty
sleep on as much as I've gotten tired of
it all I can't let go it's a habit I'm
not willing to break I think they call
that a relationship after that if we
began to remind me of her she wasn't
there I felt aimless restless
I forgot what I've been doing my hopes
my ambitions before I met her
one day I wake up feeling sluggish two
head pounding I've never felt like this
before
I automatically turn to call her I know
she'll make it better but will she make
it worse of course not
what is she a virus I'll call her
sure hey I need you to please come over
no what I don't need her I just want her
to be here
I wouldn't so there's weird this weird
years pass I can't remember much I can't
remember my friends my family will talk
won't listen while there remember is
where what the hell happened what
happened she consumed my brain is my
brain doesn't gone drip out my ears what
the [ __ ] happened nose is having a
lovely relationship as far as I could
tell the [ __ ] happened where did my life
go okay well that was weird so fairly
she's like some emotion vampire she's
gonna suck the emotions out of me if you
know what I mean
I wake up next to him this time go with
him I move to a new place recently had
found someone hey that's good I woke up
next to him again he told me hey this is
a one-time thing I have this of that and
I said yeah of course me too
here we are are you
are you an emotional vampire you're
gonna suck the emotions out of me you
should kick going get out yeah you
should get going yeah just one thing
it's been great and all but it'd be best
with the both of us if we kept this a
two-night stand that's what I'm saying
I said exactly that thirty-minute stand
you mean ha yeah ha we lasted longer
than that well I did someone else didn't
I really gotta go where to put my pants
let's see see you buddy goodbye alright
goodbye bye bye
just give I kept meeting him after that
not on purpose we just seem to be in the
right place at the right time you'd say
something like what a coincidence nice
to see you again and I'd reply [ __ ] off
I gotta I gotta go
I got I gotta go yeah well I gotta go
cool
maybe a bit blunt but there was
something off about him so I stopped
anything from developing before it was
too late say goodbye to the emotion
vampire and off you go
ok there's another mystery here I'm not
getting the answer of why this is
happening at all in the first place you
know what I mean
who is this person and why are they
sucking the emotions out of me why do I
become so dependent she told me here is
one time thinking I have this and then
they said yeah of course
wiill Dallas prick yeah yeah you you you
think that's pretty good
yeah feeling's mutual look it's been
great no it'd be best for both of us
kept this a two-night stand gang see
will we see each other again
maybe I like you I just oh hey whoa hey
whoa we got a lot of jitters well we've
been infected look I really got to go
maybe we'll see each other around the
city maybe we will maybe want to stay
for breakfast
want to stay for breakfast I've been
told I'm a great cook are good let's go
I can't deny free food all right I
cooked us breakfast conversation wasn't
as awkward as I thought it'd be who
wouldn't mind having it again I didn't
tell her that okay see then she left I
kept meeting her after that not on
purpose
we seem to just be in the right place at
the right time she'd say something like
what a coincidence nice to see you again
oh my god I've already read all this I'd
reply wanna grab a drink same want to
grab a drink what about me I don't know
do you think this is bad for us what of
course not if it makes you feel good
take a little takes a little off the
edge doesn't it not it's too much too
much that's what it is it's too much
[Music]
yeah what about we go for another round
just forget it all forget these worries
I can't you he'll make me forget all my
friends that I didn't really have that
many of in the first place no I don't
want it the can then maybe we can just
talk we don't have to do anything
I just don't lose contact I can't give
and I won't give up why are you fighting
instinct I don't
I keep fighting ah I stood my ground
I feared what would happen if I didn't
yeah and then she exploded into a ball
of light after that I refused to think
about her and she just left I never saw
her again
every night it doesn't happen I feel
strange as if I'm missing something a
crucial part of myself but as time goes
on I forget I don't mind as much my mind
clears here oh hi a good friend moved in
with me yesterday have you been
have you been hey normal for it in fact
it'll be nice to have you around again
you too so what are you up to
haven't heard from me in a long time
yeah who rubes Hicks I've just been busy
with this girl well tell me more can I
meet her nope nope evade the GABAA show
you a picture I don't know what there's
gonna do who knows [ __ ] here's a picture
no she'll become infected do here uh let
me show you you'd find it on my phone
see this pic isn't it cute there's
there's nothing there it's only you is
everything fine hate it when people
worry for me sometimes though wonder
what might happen if I told the truth
I'm not I'm not sure not sure
something's happen hey I'm here for I'm
not gonna leave again if you need me
yeah is everything fine who was that
girl I care about Thanks
hey you don't look so good I try not to
remember our time together sometimes I
remember vividly everything comes back
what's happening why my arrogant I'm
tired once more sluggish slow thoughts
more tired than I've ever been before
but I have my good friend here now to
help me let the past go defend me from
eating up one last time okay again still
confused I don't understand why kind of
understand
so is this girl made up or is this girl
Otzi so who is this friend that moved in
this real friend that don't look so good
sometimes I'm not sure I fully
understand exactly what's out of here
but maybe you guys have a better handle
owner maybe there's more endings here I
mean obviously there are multiple
endings but it doesn't have a count of
what end what endings are where you know
what I mean so like I don't know but
either way that is I woke up next to you
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think the story is
all about down the comments below if you
want to play this game for yourself and
try to find other endings I've
overlooked at the description thanks
again everybody and as always we'll see
you in the next video bye
[Music]